der leber sie sind philosoph und biologe
jüngst dieses buch hier geschrieben die
genial i tät dann sagen sie dass unser
weltbild zu einem ende gekommen sei
da frage ich mich welches weltbild denn
und werden solche überlegungen und
überzeugungen wie sie das gärten dort
mitgeteilt hat eine alternative bieten
das weltbild das an sein ende kommt ist
der dualismus und der dualismus heißt
dass wir den menschen als gesondert vom
rest der beliebten welt oder auch vom
rest des kosmos betrachten und damit
geht wirklich eine lange
geistesgeschichtliche epoche zu ende
das ist noch nicht überall angekommen
das ist jetzt sozusagen gerade der
anfang aber es ist eine fundamentale
wandlung in unserem selbstverständnis
und das selbstverständnis ist dass sich
abzeichnet ist das eine zugehörigkeit
einer gegenseitigkeit einer
durchdringung mit der welt die wir
bisher immer als die natur bezeichnet
haben und was wir eben gesehen haben ist
ein versuch diese neue welt sich die
eigentlich auch eine sehr alte weltsicht
ist das nenne ich sie meinen bei frauen
genau genau der dass nämlich der mensch
in einem verhältnis der einst des
eingefügt science in eine belebte welt
steht irgendwie wieder neu greifbar zu
machen das ist natürlich schwierig denn
die tradition auf die man sich darauf
beziehen kann sind entweder in anderen
kulturen zu finden oder aber in der
prähistorie und wir kennen sie nicht und
dadurch entstehen dann immer mischungen
die sozusagen irgendwie neu erfunden
werden und aber wir sehen dabei den
versuch eine 1 verbunden seien wieder zu
reaktivieren
was ist denn für sie die natur sie haben
uns gerade angesprochen
die natur gibt es einmal in der sandra
mainstream version die wir über sie
gesprochen haben oder sprechen und dann
ist das die welt der anderen lebewesen
die welt des unbeliebten jedenfalls eine
welt die anders funktioniert als der
mensch
die ich vor allen dingen als ressource
und als objekt gedacht und der mensch
ist derjenige der der natur immer
gegenüber steht auch der natur in sich
selbst als körper weil er nämlich über
subjektivität und sprache verfügt das
ist das alte bild wenn sie mich jetzt
fragen was ist natur
dann kann ich ihnen auch das neue bild
versuchen zu beschreiben und jetzt nicht
das schlicht juristische bild und dann
ist da muss man schon aufhören von natur
zu sprechen weil dann hat man dieses
alte schema immer drin und dann würde
ich eher vom von der lebendigen
wirklichkeit sprechen oder vom reich der
lebendigkeit und das ist eine ein
prozess einer gegenseitigen
durchdringung die individuellen gebiert
die sich nach entfaltung sehnen und
dadurch auf andere individuen angewiesen
sind also eine welt der gegenseitigkeit
die immer ein erleben ist die immer
emotional ist und an der man immer ob
man will oder nicht und wir auch als
menschen teil hat sie sagen ja auch wir
haben vergessen was es heißt zu leben da
fragen wir natürlich weshalb wissen sie
es denn was bedeutet es überhaupt zu
leben
ja ich weiß es weil ich lebe und sie
wissen ist auch weil sie auch leben und
jedes wesen weiß oder weiß es vielleicht
schon zu menschlich gesagt spürt erfährt
was es heißt am leben zu sein jedes
wesen und das können wir auch den wesen
anschauen drängt zum eigenen sein hin
zur eigenen entfaltung zur blüte und hat
entsprechend auch eine erfahrung wie gut
das funktioniert also eine erfahrung von
gut oder schlecht eine erfahrung von
gelingen oder misslingen die wir auch
aus uns selber sehr gut kennen aber sie
sagen sie wissen dass ich weiß es
deswegen konnten wir es denn vergessen
das ist eine frage auf die ich jetzt nur
vermutungen äußern kann das ist glaube
ich eine der entscheidenden fragen die
wir uns stellen müssen und das ist eine
frage auf die ich immer wieder stoße
wenn ich über diese themen über meine
themen spreche wie ist es eigentlich
dazu übergeben das ist der
naturphilosophie kann ich ja mein thema
ist eigentlich die frage wie
können wir diese welt als lebendig so
verstehen dass wir sie zugleich
anschlussfähig an unsere
wissenschaftliche diskussion halten ich
bin ja selbst biologe also wir können
wir also habe ich angefangen wie können
wir die biologie das bild vom leben so
verstehen dass wir lebewesen als
subjekte mit erfahrungen verstehen
können und die frage wie ist es
eigentlich so gekommen
das heißt vergessen dass wir es
vergessen haben die ist das ist wirklich
ein also mit einem riesigen großen
fragezeichen versehen und ich kann dazu
nur ein paar stationen benennen also ein
relevanter schritt war sicherlich im
antiken griechenland zurzeit von platon
als entschieden wurde auf die ratio zu
setzen und es gibt diese wunderbare
szene in einem der platonischen dialoge
wie sokrates zu seinen schülern sitzt
draußen vor der stadt in der natur und
sagt die bäume sie haben für uns keine
bedeutung mehr was die bäume wissen hat
für uns keine bedeutung mehr
und das ist in diesem platonischen
dialog nachgezeichnet ist der abschied
von einem weltbild in dem alles andere
so ist wie wir alles andere also auch
lebt und alles andere auch person ist
wie ist das gekommen
eine vermutung ist es gab die hoffnung
dass wir wenn wir uns auf unsere
rationale kontrolle verlassen den tod
abschaffen und wir jagen dem immer noch
nach und sehen erleben gerade dass wir
ihnen vielleicht auf diese weise immer
wieder auf neue je nach epoche
unterschiedliche art und weise erst
recht einladen aber das wäre eine idee
ist dass die die hoffnung der neben dass
selbst in die hand und sind dann nicht
mehr sterblich
ihr angestrebtes neues weltbild hängt
eben sehr stark auch mit diesem begriff
in die genial i tät zusammen können sie
das erläutern was meint denn in die
generalität ja das ist ein erstmal
natürlich ein wortspiel das viel
verspricht also es geht darum dass die
indigenen kulturen etwas geniales haben
und auch etwas was unsere kultur
vielleicht gerade jetzt dringend
brauchen ganz kurz global
zusammengefasst kann man sagen und das
schließt an die an ihre frage von
nebenan das in unserer zivilisation
schon lange eine fundamentale regel gilt
und die regel könnte man vielleicht
beschreiben mit versuche unter allen
umständen deinen tod zu vermeiden und in
den indigenen kultur und gilt eine
andere regel und die lautet alles lebt
und deswegen versuche unter allen
umständen in gemeinsamkeit das leben zu
nehmen das leben zu bewahren und so ist
also das erste erste wichtige punkt wenn
man sich indigene kulturen anguckt es
gibt ja noch ein paar und finden
natürlich auch historisch sehr viele das
alles als belebt gilt und dass man mit
all dem was belebt ist auch irgendwie
kommunizieren kann
das zweite ist das ist auch sehr wichtig
es gilt alles als eine gegenseitige
hervorbringung von fruchtbarkeit
das heißt indigene machen nicht ihr ding
und nutzen ressourcen sondern in die
gene befinden sich in einer
gegenseitigkeit man würde mit dem alten
deutschen wort sagen in einer am ende
kommen sagt man heutzutage also in einer
gemeingüter wirtschaft in der sie
beschenkt werden mit dem was sie zum
leben brauchen und dann was zurückgeben
müssen ja und diese gegenseitigkeit ist
natürlich auch eine idee die uns
vielleicht nützen kann
sie schreiben ja auch und das hört man
schon raus mit diesen indigenen dass wir
wieder wild werden müssen
jetzt habe ich mich aber gefragt wenn
sie das sagen und wir sehen das virtual
reality ein wichtiges schlagwort
geworden ist digitalisierung also starke
artifiziell ii sierung man angst hat vor
keimen et cetera
wie soll man da hin wieder zurückkommen
ja das ist auch eine von diesen fragen
die sich jetzt stellen
wichtig ist erst mal so sehen wenn ich
sage wir sind eigentlich alle wild was
natürlich ein bisschen eine provokation
ist dass unter diesem bild nicht das
wild verstanden ist des hedonistischen
der sagt lebe wild und gefährlich haben
wir richtig drauf hol dir das was zu
holen ist sondern wild heißt dass wir
verstehen können dass wir eigentlich
unseren platz fruchtbar zu sein bereits
kennen dass unser körper erkennt dass
ökosysteme wissen wie gegenseitigkeit
funktioniert und das ist er in uns etwas
gibt was wir normalerweise ausschalten
nämlich eine form von emotionaler stimme
die uns sagen kann ob eigentlich mein
leben so wie ich es führe stimmt
insofern ist dieses bild natürlich ein
es ist eben nicht das bild das wir lange
jahre jahrhundert liga zählte für die
wildnis benutzt haben als der ort des
totalen chaos
also was ist denn hier was wieso seid
ihr seid jetzt nicht so wild oder so
sagt man zu seinen kindern wenn sie
gerade alles mögliche anstellen also das
ist eine idee von wildnis die entstanden
ist in der zeit in der man sich
verabschiedet hat davon dass die bäume
etwas zu sagen haben und damit hat man
etwas ausgegrenzt was auch in uns selbst
steckt in uns selbst gibt es ja sehr
viel wildheit also wir sind eigentlich
wild wenn wir geboren werden in dem
moment ich habe zwei kinder
ich erinnere mich genau an den moment
der geburt meines sohnes als der auf
einmal vor mir lag
ja und ich wusste jetzt bin ich in der
wildnis ja also das ist was natürlich
etwas was uns menschen immer noch genau
so passiert wie uns das vor 50.000
jahren passiert ist
also das fundamentale basale körperlich
leben erleben spüren im gegenseitigkeit
das war ja eine extreme gegenseitigkeit
situation ich habe ein kind das ist
alles noch sagen wir eine eine art und
weise wie wir lebendig sind ohne dass
wir uns einen überbau geben und und da
haben wir auch dazu haben wir gefühle
und diese gefühle leiden wenn wir uns
dazu entscheiden auf all das nicht mehr
zu achten und was sie beschrieben haben
diese aktivität
das ist ja gerade darum gefährlich weil
es sich abkoppelt von dem was unsere
ureigenen bedürfnisse sind und es
koppelt sich natürlich auch weil es eine
sagen wir eine eine kommerzielle colo
realisierung einiger weniger ist die
denen es gar nicht um menschsein zu tun
ist sondern um bereicherung
was sie zu beginn gesagt haben das
führte auch so ein bisschen auf einen
animismus hin ich habe vor vielen jahren
auf dem bahnhof in göschenen diese
fragen hier gefunden flüstert der berg
schläft er hört der bergwand er sinkt
der berg träumte er das ist ein
kunstwerk von sonja kreis und da frage
ich sie
was sind ihre antworten auf diese fragen
ja gefällt mir sehr gut ich bin habe ich
mir gedacht ich bin ja ich auch deswegen
weil sie löschen denn sagen und ich
erinnere mich an die kindheits reisen
nach italien die immer irgendwie kontakt
strecke entlang finden und insofern ist
kirschen denn für mich so eine station
der verheißung
es erinnert mich noch an etwas anderes
nehmen wir es auch eine verheißung denn
diese fragen ja es gefällt mir gut
erinnert mich an etwas das mir noch
besser gefällt nämlich ein topos aus dem
aus der amerikanischen öko philosophie
von alt und leopold der sagt dass wir
wieder lernen sollten so zu denken wie
ein berg thinking gleich im mountain ist
eine ganz wichtige ganz wichtige
konfiguration in der ökologischen
philosophie und muss man sich eben
fragen das kann man sich bei diesem
gesicht gedicht natürlich auch fragen
was heißt das eigentlich denken wie ein
berg was ist das eigentlich
die anfeindungen haben dann pflanzen und
steine emotional solcherlei ja also ganz
wichtig ist dass wir bevor wir uns an
die beantwortung dieser frage machen
dass wir erst mal gucken wie reagieren
wie eigentlich wenn wir uns dem denken
eines berges aussetzen und das denken
eines berges und das ist bei alu leopold
auch sehr deutlich dass besteht erst mal
aus all den lebenden wesen die sich in
diesem berg auf diesem berg als dieser
berg begegnen immer wieder neu fruchtbar
hervorbringen das heißt ein werk denkt
zum beispiel in farben weil er sich im
herbst mit dem herbstlaub verändert ein
berg denkt in form der arten die auf ihm
leben und sich vermehren und sich
verändern und schwanken
ein berg denkt anders wenn wir den wolf
aus den weltweit eliminieren oder wenn
eine neue blumen art hinzu kommt das ist
alles das denken des berges aber wenn
wir das denken
dann kann man sich ja schon fragen ob
das nicht schon eine schwärmerische
entgleisung eben unsere kenntnisse ist
ja das kann man sich fragen ja und das
ist wäre jetzt also bis sozusagen bis
vor wenigen jahren wo diese ganze
selbstverortung auf dieser welt ins
rutschen gekommen ist wäre das
eigentlich auch die standard antwort
gewesen und ist es sie ist es immer noch
also dieses diese idee dass wir im
zugang haben können
zu dem was leben ist das nicht unser
leben ist und was sich aber auch zeigt
in seinen bedürfnissen und in seiner
seinem ausdruck von lebendigkeit und dem
bedürfnis fruchtbar zu sein das wäre
verneint worden das wird es auch immer
noch das ist also hoch kontrovers
worüber ich hier spreche ich habe jetzt
ganz bewusst deswegen im angefangen mit
der öko philosophie also leopold das ist
sozusagen noch in die in das romantische
in die romantische sichtweise irgendwie
rein zu bringen also wir sehen
den herbst und das ist nehmen wir als
das denken des berges war das ist eine
weise des lebens sich zu präsentieren
die wir von innen her verstehen können
aber man kann natürlich jetzt weiter
gehen und sagen dieser berg ist in
diesem denken vielleicht ein wesen
ja und das ist wäre sozusagen jetzt dann
klarer stärker animismus und es gibt
viele anthropologen die uns mittlerweile
im dringend nahe legen dass wir solche
denkfiguren die tatsächlich dann aus dem
denken animistisch noch immer an die
mister funktionierender völker stammen
diesmal genau anschauen sollten weil sie
vielleicht die wirklichkeit besser
darstellen als unsere
dann hat sie sich fragen was ist
gewonnen wenn wir eine animistische
sicht vertreten wie sie jetzt ja
teilweise auch tun in diesem teil
ja ja also ich glaube es ist sehr viel
gewonnen es ist nämlich als erstes
gewonnen dass unsere eigenen eindrücke
nicht mehr an der welt abprallen
normalerweise wie sie das gerade
zugesagt haben ja das ist doch aber
alles projektion ja da steht der mensch
vor der pracht anderen lebens und muss
sich selbst sagen das ist alles
einbildung und die wahrnehmung der
schönheit das ja wissen jedoch
mindestens seit kant dass es ja durchaus
vom mensch vermutlich in die natur
hineingelegt werden sie das ist nicht so
oder via genau das sage ich und kannte
ich sage auch dass kant an der stelle zu
revidieren ist ich bin nicht der einzige
das ist jetzt auch eine gerade eine
schwere zeit verkannt weil kann
natürlich diese einer der der
philosophen war der diese band in die
wirklichkeit gezogen und und das sind
alles immer überlegungen die ohne
unseren körper agieren ja das sind alles
philosophie die davon ausgehen dass wir
eine filmkamera haben die außen reize
auf eine leinwand projiziert und das ist
unser geist wir sind längst schon mit
einem körper in der landschaft und
dieser körper atmet und er atmet
ein und ein partner aus und das was er
aus atmet das atmen die bäume ein
die auf diesem berg stehen zum beispiel
aber sie haben mich ja sie habe ich was
anderes gefragt bevor wir diesen kleinen
schlenker zu bekannt gemacht aber das
war aber wichtig dass wir das gemacht
haben
sie habe mich gefragt warum ist das
wichtig warum es die animistische sicht
wichtig ja genau was ist geworden
dadurch sind weil man nimmt ja diese
also animismus kommt der animas ja die
seele da auch letztlich deswegen muss
man da gleich die seele mit einkaufen
ein weiteres metaphysisches phänomen
idee also animismus heißt im weitesten
sinne alles ist subjektiv belebt oder
alles ist beseelt das heißt nicht
unbedingt alles ist mit der christlichen
seele sozusagen begabt das heißt das
nicht unbedingt vom begriffe aber ich
will ich will das noch mal ein wollen
also einerseits finden wir uns selber in
einer welt wieder in der wir die nicht
unsere projektion ist sondern die uns
wirklich antwortet zweitens ist es so
dass eine welt die selber lebt oder der
philosoph bruno latour würde sagen die
akteur ist eine solche welt kann auch
einen raum eine rolle in politischen
entscheidungen haben und bruno latour
ist jemand einer der großen der diesen
animismus als philosophisches und sogar
politisches programm aktiviert und er
sagt ja ja ja ja ja die sardinen die
göttin der hatte aber die eben auch in
dieser wissenschaftlichen theorie von la
blog sozusagen als die ja also der die
die sich subjektiv selbst organisieren
und erhalten der erde nimmt bruno latour
wirklich zur überraschung von vielen
auch zu meiner sagte wir müssen jetzt
einfach sehen dass da ja ein akteur
geworden ist und ein akteur hat eine
politische stimme und das problem der
ökologie in all diesen jahren ist
gewesen dass sie die rechte von objekten
vertreten hat der umweltschützer haben
die rechte von dingen vertreten
rechtlich sind braunkehlchen die man
schützen möchte in einem auf einem
trockenen rasen sind objekte sind dinge
und deswegen müssen die verrechnet
werden gegen andere dinge und da ziehen
sie immer den kürzeren
das ist ein schwerwiegender vorteil ja
das ist ein großer vorteil wenn wir
sagen diese lebende welt ist ein akteur
ja und ich glaube das kann doch gar
nicht aus was das eigentlich bedeutet
also dass ein akteur in dem sie uns
antwortet und sie ist ein akteur in dem
wir mit ihrer bündnisse schmieden können
gegen eine immer weniger gegenseitigkeit
und egalität uns schenkende wenn ich
habe gelesen dass sie im frühling jeden
tag mit ihrem rad in den grunewald nach
berlin
sie leben ja in berlin gefahren sind zu
ihrer eiche
was macht diese eiche denn so speziell
für sie diese geht dabei ja das ist sehr
schön in kriege ich jetzt gleich was
empfinden sie eines extra heimweh hat
diese leiche
diese eiche ist ein werden auch eichen
in der schweiz
ich weiß ich weiß ich hatte ja auch
meine eigenen erfahrungen ist in der
schweiz also diese ich würde fast sagen
ist ein
ein mentor was lehrt sie sie denn sie
lehrt mich das zum leben das ergrünen
und die schlummernde todes ähnliche ruhe
gleichermaßen gehört sie lehrt mich dass
ein einzelner niemals nur ein einzelner
ist sondern immer viele wie es goethe
schon gesagt hat den eichen sind die
bäume die die meisten ökologischen
beziehungen haben in unseren
mitteleuropäischen ökosystemen und
eichen sind vor allen dingen bäume die
sehr alt werden können dabei aber
gleichzeitig schon so halb zersetzt foul
also in dieser eiche leben von dessen
selbst bezeugt und spechte und meisen
und es gibt fantastische riesengroße
bock käfer die in diesem wald pflegen
weil sie das alte eichenholz fressen
also diese eiche ist für mich ein ort
der fruchtbarkeit und sie ist ein
ratgeber weil sie zeigt was fruchtbar
sein heißt
das ist wirklich für mich eine immer
wieder erneuerte erfahrung
ich war sehr erstaunt sie haben in
demselben text auch geschrieben dass sie
eben die eiche dann auch ihre
zukünftigen jetzigen frau gezeigt
vorgestellt haben und dann haben sie
zusammen eine eiche gepflanzt in diesem
wald illegalerweise vermutlich diese
chance sollten nicht wo sie beschreiben
das wie ein wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere leidenschaftlicher langer kurs
ja genau
es war eine fruchtbarkeits zeremonie ja
genau also hatten wir diese kleine eiche
dann zum geburtstag geschenkt weil wir
uns eben letztlich in dem wald kennen
gelernt haben also unsere ersten dates
hatten wir im wald und nicht in einem
auf einer kaffeetasse und wir sie hat
mir diese kleine eiche geschenkt und im
winter hat sie dann erstmal eine weile
auf dem balkon gestanden weil der boden
gefroren war und dann haben wir uns
entschlossen ihr seid jetzt müssen sie
aber pflanzen weil sonst ist es zu spät
und na ja wir haben diese eiche in einer
ganz ähnlichen aktion den dem boden
geschenkt und dann dieses loch gegraben
mit den händen und haben wir mussten ja
völlig sein wir hatten kein schweres
gerät dabei und das war schon ein
bisschen ein kuss für eine berührung so
eine gegenseitigkeit das war wirklich
ein bisschen spüren dass wir selbst auf
eine ganz ganz einfache schlichte und
immer wieder neue art und weise zur erde
gehören und also das war sozusagen
miterlebt und gleichzeitig bezeugt weil
wir dabei waren weil wir es gemeinsam
gemacht haben und dann kam dieser
schreckliche sommer und deswegen habe
ich dir jeden tag begossen
das sind immer raus ich oder meine frau
aber meistens ich oder wir beide aber
ich weil ich der weil ich die meerwasser
tragen konnte also ich hab das dann auf
dem fahrrad transportiert oder im
rucksack
wir haben diese eiche gepäppelt weil sie
sonst vertrocknet wäre jetzt hat es
geschafft und jetzt gibt es sozusagen
eine neue saison los
ja das ist für mich ist das eine
erfahrung wie ein kuss weil es eben eine
erfahrung dass ihm auf
blühendes und der grünen ist und zu
blühen ist fix zu sein ist für mich die
valent ja der patronen der ökologie
zumindest in der kirche ist ja franz von
assisi der gründer des
franziskanerordens und er sagt ja
eigentlich das uns aus jedem wesen gott
entgegen leuchtet und er hat deswegen
auch mitunter zum beispiel vögeln die
evangelien gepredigt muss man denn auch
die natur erlösen ist auch die natur
erlösung bedürftig genauso wie der
mensch ja ich glaube nicht also im
gegenteil der mensch ist gerade sehr
erlösung bedürftig ich bewundere vieles
von ihm sehr der natur die evangelien zu
lesen dass wenn ich dann ein bisschen
die umkehrung ist dessen was sozusagen
eigentlich angezeigt wäre aber
nichtsdestoweniger ist in seiner haltung
ja etwas drin was ein immer wieder
wundern lässt dass er das überhaupt
überstanden hat in dieser zeit ist des
christentums in seiner blüte nämlich zu
sagen dass alles was sich leben
verbindet teil gottes ist ja das ist
sehr radikal
das ist eigentlich radikale christliche
mystik die sich dann nahtlos anschließen
lässt an mächtigen anderer religionen in
der mystik sind religion kommen sich
sehr nahe und kommen auch wieder dem
indigenen verständnis sehr nahe und das
nämlich alles was in dieser welt ist
ausdruck eines schöpfungs begehrens ist
aus sich heraus und insofern immer auch
irgendwie heilig das ist ja sehr stark
auch vertreten in indigenen haltung kann
auch nicht laut reden wenn der berg
zugehört weil er eben nur würde voll
angesprochen werden kann
mir scheint insgesamt bei ihren
ausführungen dass jedoch die natur auch
sehr glorifizieren
dann kann man aber natürlich die
gegenseite einwänden seien krankheiten
wo die ganzen bakterien mann überlebt
nur genau überlebt nur weil etwas
anderes sein leben hingibt eben ist es
nicht zu optimistisch bin froh dass sie
mir wirklich die fragen stellen die
bestellt werden müssen und
die notorischen fragen und mir passiert
ist dass je nach dem wie ich die
geschichte erzähle man mehr entweder
sagt ich glorifizieren die natur oder
aber man sagt mir ich zeichne zu
düsteres bild weil ich immer vom tod
sprechen
das entscheidende an dem moment der
gegenseitigkeit ist dass wir darin in
unser eigenes sterben einwilligen
ökosysteme als große allmende sind auch
nahrungsketten und ich sagte ja schon am
anfang auf ihre frage etwas nachdenklich
wieso ist es eigentlich ist es
eigentlich dazu gekommen dass wir uns
davon abgewandt haben das war die idee
dass wir dem tod davonlaufen können
und selbstverständlich ist der
zusammenhang des lebens ein dauerndes
geboren werden und ein dauerndes sterben
und gleichwohl ist es ein dauerndes
geboren werden und nicht eben nur der
tod aber es ist total klar also ich sage
eigentlich immer sehr gerne dass wenn
wir wirklich lebendig sein wollen dann
müssen wir uns essbar machen im essbar
sein
ich weiß nicht wie glorifizieren sich
das jetzt anhört aber es war sein dass
erhalt uns ja alle am ende unseres
lebens
dann werden wir gegessen und schenken
uns zurück diesem großen gloriosen
kreislauf den wir die ganze zeit schon
angehören
man könnte aber auch ganz böse sagen
dass aufgrund dieser ganzen
klimakatastrophe was letztlich auch ihre
spray plädoyer aufs tapet holt die er
hat einfach auf unser verschwinden
wartet und eigentlich sind wir die
missetäter die natur kommt gut ohne uns
zu recht ja ich meine so wie sie die
frage stellen haben wir wieder zwei
seiten da gibt es die natur und den
menschen ich habe habe ich nicht
verstehen
nein es ist ich mache das auch bauen
weil uns das sehr schwer fällt wenn wir
unsere chancen hoffnung das sind ja ja
unser also dass die natur ist ein
begriff der ist geprägt worden in einer
bestimmten haltung und wir benutzen ihn
deswegen ist es wichtig dass man sich
selber immer wieder darauf aufmerksam
machen dass ich sagen will ist wir
können jetzt aus einer system
perspektive sagen
eine außerordentlich erfolgreiche art
die dabei ist ihre eigenen ressourcen zu
verbrauchen und weiß dass aus der
biologie dass es irgendwann zu einem
population zusammenbruch führt und so
kann man das sich angucken also so ist
sozusagen die kann man die geschichte
erzählen und im augenblick sieht es so
aus als würde ist alles ein bisschen
enger und ein bisschen knapper jetzt
habe ich gerade gehört das 70 jahre
schneller als erwartet der permafrost in
kanada auftauen
wir sind leider fast schon am ende
unseres gesprächs wir könnten noch sehr
lange weiter reden und ich hätte auch
noch sehr viele fragen dann sehe ich
aber eine allerletzte frage die sie
deswegen auch ganz sehr kurz bitte
beantworten wenn sie die möglichkeit
hätten zum baum der erkenntnis oder vom
baum des lebens die frucht zu nehmen
welche würden sie nehmen
ich nehme die frucht vom baum des lebens
die ganze zeit täglich dauernd und
insofern halte dein kw dafür dieses
gespräch ebenfalls finden die frage was
bewusstsein überhaupt ist gehört wohl zu
den ältesten fragen der philosophie
barbara bleisch sucht mit dem
australischen philosophen david charles
nach dem bewusstsein und fragt könnte es
nicht sein dass alle um uns herum nur
zombies sind auf wiedersehen
[Musik]